hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
section 9 of David hume's inquiry
concerning human understanding is titled
of the reason of animals and before
launching into
the various points that are made there
we should observe something which is
that this term reason or reasoning is
used in kind of a double sense in this
action Hume wants to say that there's
you know reasoning or argumentation that
is something explicit that we human
beings do at least some of the time when
it comes to like making decisions or
carrying out geometric proofs or perhaps
doing philosophy or engaging in the
other disciplines you know the sort of
things that a writer him or herself is
doing in writing their their book about
say the human understanding
there's also what he's going to call
experimental reasoning which he says
that we human beings share in common
with the Beast that is with non-human
animals so animals do reason in one
sense although they don't reason in
another sense of the term and this is
going to
bring us to an interesting question
which requires a little bit of setup so
he tells us at the very beginning all of
our reasonings concerning matter of fact
are founded on a species of analogy
right so we're constantly relying upon
analogizing or analogies in order for us
to understand our very experience and
manage anything in the world what does
this do this species of analogy leads us
to expect from any cause the same
effects which we've observed to result
from similar causes and he says well you
know we have perfect and imperfect cases
so you know where the resemblance is
very very close perhaps so close that we
can't see any real difference you know
for example pieces of chalk you know
what if you know one piece of chalk you
probably know what's going on with the
other track we should expect it to write
on the board in the same way to have the
same properties now now if we move to
things that are not quite so similar
then we have imperfect analogies and
this doesn't mean that we don't buy into
them but we don't have the same degree
of certainty or the same you could say
intensity of belief
and so he says that you know there's a
proportion to the degree of similarity
and resemblance at least as far as we
understand it right we could be mistaken
about this then he goes on and he says
that you know let's use animals as an
example the anatomical observations
formed on one animal are by this species
of reasoning extended to all animals and
it is certain that when the circulation
of the blood is clearly proven to have
place in one creature like a frog or a
fish it forms a strong presumption that
the same principle has placed in all and
so you know think about like if you've
ever taken a high school biology class
where you had to do some dissection of
worms or frogs or fetal pigs or other
animals you know you don't go around and
like dissect every single animal to be
sure that there's a circulatory system
it's enough to dissect one and to rely
on the testimony given by our textbooks
and our teachers that what goes for this
goes for others but even if we didn't
have them saying that we would say yeah
I I think that these are pretty similar
so if I cut open this frog and find a
heart and you know veins and all you
know they're going into all these things
it's probably the same in that frog over
there
so you know we rely on this quite a bit
for understanding animals and then he
says well these analogical observations
may be carried further even to this
science of which we're now treating that
is the topics of the inquiry concerning
the human understanding and he says any
Theory by which we explain the
operations of the understanding or the
origin and connection of the passions in
human beings which is you know what a
lot of this is about
um you know the passions get treated a
little bit more in the other inquiry but
um if we can find something similar
going on not just in all human beings
but in our other animals because we're
animals right then this will as he says
acquire additional Authority if we find
the same Theory as requisite to explain
the same phenomena in all other animals
so you know this is actually worth
pausing on for a moment we're going to
strengthen our human theory about the
understanding and the passions of humans
by looking at animals
all animals
I don't know maybe not a mosquito you
know maybe we want to look at uh
otters and Bears or horses and and dogs
as he prefers to do instead
um maybe there's vital differences
between certain types of animals but if
we stick to the ones that are closer to
us I think hume's argument becomes much
more plausible and he provides us with a
couple uh reasons for thinking that this
is the case the first one is quite you
know interesting and I think kind of
commonsensical he says it seems evident
animals as well as human beings learn
many things from experience and infer
that the same events will always follow
from the same causes now again
Hume is is being a little bit uh
General with this it should be that
animals don't always you know learn that
the same events will always follow from
the same causes there should be a degree
of probability there right anybody says
by this principle they become acquainted
with the more obvious properties of
external objects and gradually from
their birth acquire a knowledge of the
nature of notice the examples he's going
to give fire water Earth Stones Heights
depth Etc and of the effects that follow
from their operation so you know stick
your little paw in the fire and it gets
burned and you're like oh I don't like
that right you learn don't touch the
fire right you drink the water and the
water tastes good and you know quenches
your thirst now you know that don't fall
in the water and go underneath because
you might drown unless of course you're
the kind of animal that swims around in
water right
and how can we tell that learning is
taking place
well the differences between young and
old animals and he gives some examples
of horses and Greyhounds that we don't
need to necessarily go through and then
he talks about how we human beings can
also help to educate or discipline this
process within animals you know think
about the the thing with throwing the
ball and the dog goes running even
though the ball is in your hand you do
that a few times when the dog comes back
and is ticked off with you because it
realizes you've been tricking it
it ran in the first place because of the
many times that you would actually throw
the ball and it observed you doing this
motion and the ball being downfield and
then it can go and get its its ball and
you know bring it back to you or do
whatever else it's going to do chew on
it you know keep it away from other dogs
that is a process of disciplinary
education right all sorts of other
things I mean he's got examples of like
showing the dog the stick that you used
to beat it with hopefully you're not
beating your your pets but in hume's
time this is very common and the dog you
know actually he talks about not just a
stick but a whip right uh but you know
these are all examples of discipline and
education you can think about the effect
of feeding a pet right when that pet
hears the kibble bag rustling or the can
opener opening and the sound of things
being put into its bowl it's like oh
it's time to eat how does it know
because there's no like natural
connection between those well you know
education of sorts right so this is uh
quite clear and he says that in all
these cases we may observe the animal
infer some fact beyond what immediately
strikes his senses and that this
inference is founded on past experience
just like with us right so there's a
strong analogy there between us and
other animals
what about
the inferences that animals are drawing
so here we get to the second argument
that he's making this is a very
interesting one with some pretty
important implications
he says it's impossible the inference of
the animal can be founded on any process
of argument or reasoning by which he
concludes like events must follow like
objects and that the course of nature
will always be regular in its operations
why him says if there be in reality any
arguments of this nature
they surely lie to obtrus for the
observation of such imperfect
understandings the understanding that an
animal has since it may well employ the
utmost care and attention of the
philosophic genius to discover and
observe them right
so here's where we get to the very
interesting uh
matter that that comes to light him says
you know not only do animals not engage
in any sort of explicit process of
argumentation or reasoning neither do
most humans
children don't do that I mean we can say
well wait a second I've encountered kids
who can you know like spell out why they
want to do something okay put that aside
for the moment for the most part kids
aren't doing that right and they don't
do it as much as adults do certainly
and even most adults
aren't doing this most of the time he
says the generality of mankind and their
ordinary actions and conclusions aren't
doing this
and even the philosophers philosophers
in their books in their classes are
doing this but that's kind of fake
that's not what they're doing most of
the time he says in all the active parts
of life philosophers are in the main the
same with the vulgar and are governed by
the same maxims so how does this
actually happen
for animals and for us custom which
humans talked about quite a lot in the
previous sections of the work he says
it's custom alone which engages animals
from every object that strikes their
senses to infer its usual attendant and
Carries their imagination from the
appearance of the one to conceive the
other in that particular manner which we
denominate belief he says no other
explication can be given of this now
notice
something very important here
by contrast to many other philosophers
of his time who treat animals as if
they're essentially just machines made
of meat have no real Consciousness Hume
says that they have an understanding
they have passions they have imagination
they even have this thing that we
denominate or call belief animals at
least some of them are much much closer
to human beings than and for Hume than
many other people make them out to be
uh a third thing that he talks about is
the role of instincts and he's going to
bring something very interesting to
light now how do animals carry out a lot
of their sort of inferences some of it
is on the basis of experience a lot of
it is on the basis of instinct something
that's born into them we might call it
their genetic programming or something
like that and uh he tells us that you
know although animals learn many parts
of their knowledge from observation
there's many parts they derive from the
original hand of nature right and he
says that they don't need to learn this
as a matter of fact it doesn't do them
any good to like practice their
instincts these we denominate instincts
and we're you know an admiration of them
holy crap look at how this animal can
figure this thing out even though you
know it never got taught that like you
know think about birds flying right a
lot of that is instinctual
um you know if they had to like stop and
think about what they're doing it would
probably be like those those cartoons
where we see the animal go off the cliff
and like you know look down think about
what's happening and then they fall
directly down right
but
we also have instincts and you know I'm
not just talking about things like our
startle instinct or you know infants
suckling at the breast Hume tells us
that this entire functioning of custom
is itself instinctual
he tells us that we should consider the
experimental reasoning itself okay so
now that's another thing I wanted to to
call your attention to here is where
Hume is saying that this custom is
experimental reasoning that's clearly
reasoning in a different sense than
explicit reasoning
because he tells us we possess this
experimental reasoning in common with
beasts and on which the whole conduct of
life depends is nothing he tells us but
a species of instinct or mechanical
Power and it acts in us he says unknown
to ourselves it's in its chief
operations it's not directed by any
relations or comparison of ideas as are
the proper objects of our intellectual
faculties much of the time you could say
we're working on autopilot right or
following programming that we have and
that is experimental reasoning for both
ourselves and for beasts or other
animals there is one uh last thing that
we
ought to discuss in some of the versions
of the text we have a long footnote in
which Hume is saying that it might be
asked how it happens that human beings
so much surpass animals and reasoning
and one human being so much surpasses
another doesn't custom work the same way
on all of them and here's where Hume
says no there's important differences
between human beings
and he gives a whole list of nine
different uh factors then he says
there's all the many other circumstances
that make a difference I'm not going to
go into them so the first one he says
when we've lived anytime and been
accustomed to the uniformity of nature
we acquire a general habit by which we
transfer the known to the unknown and
conceive the latter to resemble the
former and so you know this is uh quite
important and uh so you know how do you
do this by observing the consequences of
things and so because some people
surpass others in attention memory
paying you know observation to things
this is going to make a difference you
know you could say some people take in
more data than other people do he also
says where there's a complication of
causes to produce any effect one mind
might be larger more able to take in
different things and better able to
comprehend the whole system of objects
and to infer justly their consequences
third he says one person is able to
carry on a chain of consequences to a
greater length than another fourth he
says few people can think long without
running into a confusion of ideas some
people are better than this than others
fifth the circumstance on which the
effect depends is frequently involved in
other circumstances which are foreign
and extrinsic being able to separate
these out requires Great attention
accuracy and subtlety people are
different in those respects six forming
General maxims from particular
observations it varies he says nice
operation meaning we have to pay close
attention to what we're doing and
nothing is more usual from a haste or
narrowness of Mind than to commit
mistakes seven when we reason from
analogies the person who has a greater
experience or the greater promptitude in
suggesting analogies is going to be the
better Reasoner
eight biases from Prejudice education
Passion Party affect some people more
than others and then finally nine after
we have acquired a confidence in human
testimony books and conversation enlarge
much more the sphere of one person's
experience and thought than another so
there's these nine different factors
that make some people better at
analogizing other people not quite so
good at it and so that produces a
difference in the way custom works and
we could probably say that some of these
would apply to animals as well you know
maybe some animals are just better at
drawing analogies some are smarter some
are a little bit Freer of their
instincts and we could go on and on and
on as well but we see that for David
Hume in this chapter there's a lot of uh
similarity between how the human mind
works and how animal minds work